if you increase the quality of your
prospects you will increase the quality
of your product at gym launch we figured
out that gym owners that were the most
successful had three things in common
assigned lease they had at least one
employee they had at least 30 customers
so if someone has all three of those
things they'll make a ton of money with
our thing we told the sales team them we
said if they don't have these three
things do not sell them we told the
marketing team say this in all of our
marketing if they don't have these two
things tell them this is not for them so
what happened we sold better people
guess what happened after that our
average results went up guess what we
can do after that market our average
better results and what do we do get
better customers and so it becomes a
virtuous cycle that improves the product
here's the crazy part we didn't actually
change anything about what we sold we
changed who we sold it to